yeah so what happens is like let's say
you're sitting on a couch watching TV
and then she comes in he's like oh you
don't have to get up and she cleans and
her boobs go like this oh
has anybody here ever hired a topless
maid no yeah you know I have I know you
have yeah I have it I regret not doing
it are they still available they so
there is a Tampa Florida woman who makes
300 an hour as the topless made wow dang
that's crazy 300 an hour that is way
more than we spent what did you guys
spend it was definitely two digits I was
gonna really yeah I didn't did she did
she actually clean no that's me yeah
well no she didn't she tried aren't you
supposed to hire her and then like tip
yeah wall that's what that's where you
make the money yeah but you just wanted
her to clean I mean even the van the
pink Van around Hollywood tells you it's
like 90 bucks or something oh wow that's
just to get them too that's to get them
to park the van yeah in front of you or
away from your building that's what we
were worried about we're like are they
gonna come in that pink van and just
park it in front of now if I was a
prostitute I'd be pissed at you what
because I'll be like I came to suck some
dick I'm not here to [__] clean your
she was pissed oh wait did but they
they're prostitutes I always want not
always but I think it's fair to say that
somewhere open so it's fair to say that
they're all [__] kind of it's fair to
say they're not going to heaven yeah
well that depends on your definition
baby you know my version of Heaven could
be a little bit different 900 an hour is
it's that's great and she and she's
getting a lot of business right she's
doing sometimes five houses in a day
whoa 300 an hour plus I mean she is
definitely not cleaning hours in a day
five thousand a day and are these small
houses what's that small houses it
doesn't say even cleaners can't do five
hours yeah I did she dude she's making
so much bank that she actually employs a
security guard who Waits outside in the
car
there's another word business
what would be his name
we're gonna hear her break it down oh
nice Straight From the Source
oh she's topless right now today I
cleaned five houses and I charged 300.
and I also have a security guy that sits
in the car outside and waits for me I
wouldn't pay for that
where is this
they gave me a hundred and fifty dollar
tip I just want to say it's not required
to tip but majority of the houses that I
clean they do too second house 300 for
the hour and they gave me a 120 tip
third house 300 for the hour and they
gave me a nice 150. can't believe this
is on ESPN 300 for the hour
and ten dollars
tip of 200. hey Steve you've been
looking at Boots recently or what you
know you know what's really interesting
it is everyone's tipping 50
which means
there's a there's an added service what
do you think there is you don't think
she's she's probably getting in between
like the grout and the tiles
she's actually doing a really good job
she either is like Primo yeah cleaner
maybe I would pay maybe I would pay 300
because like if you think about it right
like sometimes these they come in teams
of like six people and they take like
seven hours and you're like what the
[__] are you doing bro if she could do
this in one hour but is she really
cleaning these joints in one she must be
she says she's deep cleaning yeah dude I
don't think so oh she's deep cleaning
for sure I mean I mean she could yeah
I think I have this I have it all wrong
like I I thought that she would just be
in a French maid outfit she's not she's
just she's actually oh she is funny
because she's literally in a French [__]
yeah what do you think well how come she
didn't do that in the video
she was explaining it she was explaining
it well I thought she would wear that
every day yeah here she is right I
thought that was her day yeah that I
want to get into how did the French maid
outfit become like the quintessential
made outfit do other countries have made
outfits I think everyone wants to [__]
their maid kind of right yeah but how
did the French one become like the sex
scene made because French were very
stylish by the sexiest one yeah yeah
they probably have the cool stuff I
think what does an Indian maid wear a
sorry she's already her stomach is
already
and there you go she's already halfway
there this has got buttons and like lace
you probably gotta untie it it's cute
the sorry is literally just unwrapped
you're not a fan of the French maid
outfit no I'm just curious how that
became
post French Revolution you think it's
played out because pre-frame Revolution
was pretty like no pretty like how many
people have French mates other than the
French
if you're rich maybe we're not
Aristocrats so we would exactly yeah if
you're rich you you get a French maid
what's the common mate you get a British
Butler I think they clean their own
house like we ain't Bruce Wayne here
yeah cool for 300 an hour maybe she's
wearing [__] Frenchman outfit yeah
she's definitely not fully cleaning any
houses you don't think so no way because
then if it's per hour oh so this is
[__] she's pouring like fake milk
into her fake chai that's what she's
doing what if she's just cleaning really
small houses like the cleaning is just a
task that they do while you watch it's
like it's a thing where they it's like
dancing it's a show yeah it's a show
yeah but in dancing you actually dance
are they actually like cleaning yeah so
what happens is like let's say you're
sitting on a couch watching TV and then
she comes in he's like oh you don't have
to get up and she cleans and her boobs
go like this oh
Joe is in dude
can you do that again that was a great
impression you know what I mean she saw
the specificity he was like so what
happens she gets really close and then I
felt her left breast just graze against
my eyelash he's like watching TV and he
gets smashing his face he's like please
get get up I can't I can't see Stephen A
Smith get out of my face and then he's
like drinking his soda and he's like oh
[__] I spilled it and can you clean it
and so she goes in front of him she
makes a mess and then cleans it now dude
what kind of porn are you watching and
then and then and then he's sipping his
coffee and he goes oh no and she goes I
got it and then she takes off his
clothes and then starts sucking his dick
because it needs to be clean yeah no
she's you mean she's sucking the coffee
off of his dick oh yeah that's true
it says here she uses Ajax on pots
porcelain bathroom fixtures it's all
normal [__] I wonder if I wonder if
that's just a really good version of
that service
because in in our experience for the one
in La it's very rigid what happened well
they they she came in and she's very
like she doesn't act sexy she's just
like okay it's gonna be this much
Hollywood baby if anybody else comes
around and sees me besides you extra 60
per person like no it's per person
watching her do it that's lame yeah it
is very lame and it's like a and I think
obviously the object of the
um of the objective of her coming over
is that you want to do more stuff so
you're willing to tip for this amount is
it smarter to get a topless made because
then you're actually watching the whole
time so they can't steal your stuff
that's why I had to watch her though but
then they're also doing a poor job of
cleaning like your story that you told
yeah she was she was highly upset that
she had to actually clean oh so it's
probably not in the gig she didn't she
didn't have any cleaning products I
don't I don't buy the story This Girl's
worked five apartments and she cleans
for one hour she can't pressure wash my
car
clearing 5
.5
Apartments five actually cleaning five
bathrooms I don't give a [__] you can't
clean one room in an hour bro it feels
like you're deep cleaning that's why
it's not it's not cleaning it's like
she's probably actually like doing them
we should get all of our you know Asian
moms to judge her and be like let's see
what her cleaning again unless this is
just a different service that's actually
cleaning I don't know yeah does she have
a feather duster and does this 300 an
hour and almost every customer gave her
150 tip but is it one customer though
because what if guys get this like for a
party like it's like a strip show I just
hire strippers right and then hire
cleaners and have them there at the same
time oh wait get wild you know what a
better question is do you think like
like strippers that make house calls got
beef with topless maids you think
they're guaranteed you think there's
[__] like I wonder what they would
say about Tapas especially this chick
because apparently she [__] uses
common bleach on your toilets damn yeah
she's like you shouldn't be using is
that in the contract that better be the
contract I don't think they will they'll
even touch the a bathroom no she says
she does drains she says she she takes
Drano she uses dual Max adrenal too they
don't do plumbing she's got one of those
water vacs you know used for flooding
yeah yes she shot me yeah she's got a
shot she's got a shot back the one
that's like it's like cylindrical on
Wheels and the hose like I can fit in
the hose do you think these snakes
drinks it says here she advises you not
to declutter before she gets there
because that's part of what she does
she's a marine condo she just like a
throw stuff I'm pretty sure it's like a
Friday or Saturday she's working right
and then it's like she she does five
houses makes like two grand a day she
only has to work like a couple days a
week that's tight yeah yeah pretty much
but I'm sure the demand is I'm sure the
demand is pretty high for that is it is
it I think so like who's getting it on a
Wednesday but here's the thing people
are not getting it to get they're not
getting it for cleaning service they're
getting it because they want private
stripper shot this is her this is the
vacuum yeah
this is great she's got her own brand
shop vac nice job you're gonna have that
on your target she's licensing she's
licensing shopping cookies on I think a
lot of people get them because it's like
a thing where you want to see that but
you don't want to feel the I don't know
like it's like it's yeah there's a guilt
with getting a stripper or something
like people definitely do get them like
it's weird we gotta get a customer that
really gets this stuff and then like
just hey would you call me I'd come over
and clean your place topless
foreign